- All right, moving on.
Our first guest has been
one of the most beloved
and distinguished gentlemen
of Hollywood for decades.
I love him.
He has saved the world in many movies like
"Independence Day",
"Jurassic Park",
as well as with his music.
His latest EP is called,
"Plays Well with Others".
I am one of those others
he plays well with on the record.
I am very excited about it.
It's available wherever
you get your music.
Give it up for Mr. Jeff
Goldblum, everybody.
(jazz music)
(audience cheers)
Are you gonna lay down?
- Huh? No, I'm not gonna lay down.
(Kelly laughs)
(loud crash)
- I like it.
See?
This is, this is when you know, wait,
this is when you know you're tall.
Because I have to have
so many pillows behind me
cause I have no legs.
So, you turned 70 since
you were here last.
And you did,
you did something really cool.
You did something really
cool to celebrate.
I love where you went.
Tell everybody what you did.
- My cool and wonderful
wife, Emily Goldblum,
surprised me.
I've never done this.
She's done other surprises.
But she said, oh, there she is.
Wow. And here we are.
So this is it.
She said,
"Hey, show up.
You know, bring a bathing suit.
I'm not gonna tell you.
I've made plans.
I'm not gonna tell you where we're going."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she put me in a
car and then in a train.
I was like, well, I don't
know where we're going.
And she took me to,
some, we were near,
we were in Italy already.
And she took me to Positano.
If you've ever heard of it.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] I've been there.
It's beautiful.
- [Jeff] You've been there?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I had never been there.
- Beautiful.
- I'd heard about, it's
really spectacular,
isn't it?
- Yeah!
- So.
- like a movie.
Like you're in a movie the whole time.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And they live there.
Those people.
- Yeah, I know.
- Yeah.
- I know.
What were you doing in Italy?
And I, I love Italy.
Do you speak Italian?
- No, ciao.
(everyone laughs)
Nope.
- Ciao, that's something.
- Yeah.
Nope, no.
I know more Spanish.
I know it's all Latin based, but, yeah.
No, no. Italiano.
You're such an easy person to talk to.
You love talking.
Have you always been like this?
Were you ever shy?
Caus people think that
I've always been talkative
and I was actually super shy.
- Really?
- Until music.
And then
- Really?
- that kind of, my whole
personality blossomed.
Were you shy as a kid or no?
- I love what you just said.
You know, I think the arts
for those listening,
to whom it may matter,
can transform
otherwise expand,
- Yes.
- and save, in some cases your life.
Like my sister Pam with painting,
it changed,
and I think saved her life.
With me,
I would've been a different
kind of person right now
if I had been a doctor like my dad
or done something else.
But acting,
just like maybe you were singing,
I did music too.
Both of those things,
have made me what I am today,
which is
- Yeah!
such as a,
- No, that's true.
- Such as I'm for good,
the good and the bad,
you know,
- The good and the bad, yeah.
But it has opened me up.
The arts can open you up
and so can singing and,
I've enjoyed what it can do to me.
So, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I was shy before,
but you know, I had seeds of
you know, gregariousness when I was a kid.
Yeah, you know.
- I would've loved to have picked,
like me picturing you as a kid,
is still very suave and
charismatic and like,
like you as a kid is still like,
I feel like you showed up in suits.
- Well, I'll tell you.
No, I wasn't in suits,
although I was always interested
in clothing a little bit.
But my mom used to take me to
Horne's department store in Pittsburgh.
And, but, I remember,
you made me think of my first
dance in seventh grade.
- Oh, when you do this and this.
- Yeah. Kind of like that.
You do a box tie,
and my mom had taught me the box-step
and you know when.
- Yeah. And my mom told me,
leave room for the Lord.
(everyone laughs)
- How big is the Lord?
- It's, I had short arms.
So luckily for me!
- Oh, I see the Lord.
Oh, I see.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Oh, I think you can,
I think the Lord sometimes
- Leave room for the Lord.
- the Lord wants us to,
wants us to be close.
- She did not agree.
- Oh, she the Lord, or your mom.
She the Lord.
(Kelly laughs)
So I was at the,
I was in our gymnasium
and I asked Cindy Shaw,
"Hi Cindy Shaw.
I haven't seen you since..."
I've never, I haven't talked
to her in all these years.
But, she was my first dance.
(Kelly gasps)
And I thought
- I love that you
remember this.
- Yeah.
And I thought,
what should, do you
talk when you're dancing
or should we just kind of dancing?
And, and, and I think she said, you know,
I'm watching my,
we started talking about something
eat or something.
And she said,
"I'm watching my waist.
I'm trying to watch my waist."
And I said, you made me think of it.
I said, well Cindy, I'd rather watch it.
(Kelly yells)
(audience cheers)
You know.
- If it's alright with you,
I'll take care of that for you.
See! You were that kid!
You're like,
- Maybe,
I might have been creepy
or I might have been suave.
Whatever I was,
(Kelly laughs)
whatever you think.
(Kelly claps)
- So wait, so let's talk about your music.
I love your music so much.
So how old were you?
Cause you're such a great pianist.
I love,
- Thank you.
- I love your whole vibe musically.
So you must have started young, right?
- I did when I was 10.
You know, my kids are playing, but
they beat me to it.
- Oh, really?
And I started after them.
They're seven and five,
but I started I think nine and 10,
you know.
- Yeah.
- Like that and took piano lessons.
You play, a what, you play.
- I played piano when I was a kid.
I took lessons when I was very young.
And then I didn't have anything
to really practice on.
So, yeah.
And then I switched to violin.
I got a violin from something
and then we couldn't afford that.
It was all just, you know,
vocals are free, Jeff.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
I didn't need money.
- Yeah. But not all of us are possessed
of a Stradivarius, you know
- Well, no
- in our vocal chords.
- Well, it pushed me to be a vocalist,
cause I just couldn't
afford anything else.
So. Yeah.
- Oh my gawd.
- But I love, I love playing.
I was not good at it.
I'm not good at it.
But, so you played since you
were 10 and then did you,
- Yeah, yeah.
- Did you play constantly,
or did you kind of let it go for a minute?
- Oh no, I played constantly.
I, you know, I had the idea
I wanted to be an actor.
I had that career idea,
but I played,
and I was a bad student, really.
I did not know the joys of discipline yet.
So the piano teacher would
come and I hadn't practiced
and I would be, you know,
unhappy and he would be unhappy.
But then,
Tommy Amel, but then he gave me a piece
of an arrangement for Ally Cat
and for Moon River and
for different things.
And I went,
Ooh, these chords are different than this,
just classical exercises that I was doing.
And I'm in love with it
and now I'm just gonna sit and play
as long as it takes
- Yeah.
- to be able to do that.
And I fell in love with it.
That's why I started
to get a little better.
And then I started to play out and about.
I got a yellow pages,
and looked at cocktail lounges,
up around Pittsburgh,
and got a couple of gigs
when I was like 15,
and started to play around and about,
you know.
- See, you've always been a grown dude.
Like, you're like cocktail lounges.
That's incredible.
I didn't even know what
that was when I was 15.
I actually did cause of
Doris Day films, but,
anyway.
- You're from Texas.
- Texas.
- So with Doris Day movies,
- Yeah.
that's right.
- I love Dor, yeah.
- Did you?
- I love Doris Day films.
- She's...
- Yeah. Rock Hudson.
- Really? I saw the "Pillow Talk"
and I saw those when I was a kid.
- Yeah I loved them.
I was obsessed.
When I'm sad,
just so you know world.
- Yes.
- When I get really sad.
- Mm-hm.
- If you come in my house
and you see me looking at "Pillow Talk",
if you see me watching "Pillow Talk",
just leave the house.
(everyone laughs)
It's not going well.
- Okay.
- That's my thing I turn on
to just like, pep up.
- Makes you feel good?
- Yeah.
- Really?
- Do you have a movie like that?
Please say "Jurassic Park"
or something or yours!
(everyone laughs)
- Please say like,
"All my own work."
- Well,
- That would be amazing.
- I do like,
"The Wizard of Oz",
you know,
- Oh, me too, me too.
And I just, I'm not
supposed to talk about it,
but I just worked with your friend,
Ariana Grande.
- Oh yeah.
- Because she's,
- Yes!
- because she's in "Wicked".
- I know.
- Along with Cynthia
- Erivo
- and Michelle Yeoh.
- Yeah.
- And I'm in it.
Anyway, I can't say
anything more about it.
- I'm gonna love it.
I've seen the actual production, "Wicked",
maybe seven to 10 times.
I don't even know how many.
- Really?
- Yeah, I love it.
I kept taking different people.
- Yeah. I took my kids
and Emily this last time
in London where we shot.
- Oh wow.
- And I was crying
throughout the whole thing.
It's if you know that show.
- Yeah.
- It just kills me.
I had seen the, the originally
with Idina Menzel and Kristin Chenoweth.
- Yeah.
- And it just kills me.
That show, you know,
- All right.
I'm excited to have you
see that.
- I wanna tell 'em
this though, we're performing,
"Don't Fence Me In",
which is a song you
actually asked me to sing
when you were on here
with "Jurassic World",
when the cast,
when they were on here,
- I hope it wasn't
too presumptuous, yeah, we were-
- Oh my God, no!
- But
I kinda put you on the spot, I said,
"Hey!"
- Well, we had kinda
played together a little bit
on a Hollywood game night.
You were on the piano,
we were all singing around it.
- That's right.
- So I was excited about it,
but I had never heard
of "Don't Fence Me In".
So how did, what does
this song mean to you?
- Cole Porter, you know, wrote it.
The lyrics are great.
I didn't know all that much about it.
The lyrics are,
and which I didn't,
even after I asked you to do it,
it only occurred to me later I went,
wait a minute.
She's singing the first thing she sings,
you'll see is,
- That's awesome.
- Is about Wild Cat Kelly.
She sings, it's about Wild Cat.
I went, wait, that's her!
That's her!
She's singing about herself, you know,
et cetera, et cetera.
- So when I first heard it,
like, and I was like, oh my God.
Cause I didn't know it was,
I just didn't know my name was in it.
I was like, you asked me to sing a song
with my name and it's awesome.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I was like...
- Is there another song
with your name in it?
- I don't think so.
- That's the only one
that I know.
- So now this is now
my favorite song.
Yeah.
- Well mine too now because
of you and what we did.